hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast the science of
farm-to-table sourdough bread is a
microcosm of the global food crisis
presented by Rob Dunn professor of
applied ecology at North Carolina State
University
I am Marjory tourist of lab roots and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
we are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by
Lavery's labret is a leading scientific
social networking website and producer
of educational virtual events and
webinars before we begin I would like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the green Q&A button located in the
lower left of the presentation window
and type your questions into the box
that appears on the screen
well answer as many questions as we have
time for at the end of the presentation
also please notice that you will be
viewing the presentation and slide
window to enlarge to the note just click
on the screen icon located on the lower
right if you have trouble seeing or
hearing the presentation please click on
the support button a top right of the
presentation window or use the Q&A
button to let us know that you're having
a problem this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits please click on the
button in the bottom left corner and
follow the process to obtain your
credits please join me in welcoming dr.
Rob Gunn I will now turn the
presentation over to him
thank you so much for having me here
today but I want to talk about is a
little bit about the ways in which
sourdough bread is a key part of our
future
and if we think about start over and
it's a kind of funny thing what you do
to make sourdough bread is you take a
little bit of flour a little bit of
water you mix them together microbes
arrived from somewhere from your hands
from the air and the bread and the water
and they start to ferment and that
fermentation is at the heart of the
leavening and bread it's at the heart
with all of bread culture it's the heart
at the heart really of much of Western
culture we don't think about this very
much at all and it doesn't seem like it
should be deferred of any kind of future
really it's a good thing it's a special
thing but I'm going to argue that if we
think about sort over bread we see some
solutions to many of our problems and if
we haven't had good solutions to in the
past but before I bring you this
sourdough bread I want to take you to a
very different direction which is to
think about global agriculture and
specifically in the context of global
agriculture I'm going to talk about the
pests and pathogens but crops now you
may be more familiar with thinking about
the pests and pathogens of humans this
happens to be a map from one of our
studies of the number of kinds of pests
and pathogens of humans in different
political regions so redder areas have
more kinds of human pathogens but we can
think about the same kind of thing
happening with their crops except we
would have a different map a different
list of demons for each one of our crops
and this matters because one of the
things that we've done to our crops we
could dramatically change their ability
to respond to those pests and pathogens
and this is a general topic I've written
about little book never read of sivan
season which will be the backdrop for a
lot of what I talk about today a key
piece of what we've changed that makes
our crops more susceptible to pests and
pathogens is the number of kinds of
crops that we were relying on and we can
think about this in a bunch of different
ways there
one very visceral way is to think about
what kind of waste we produce and so if
you go to New York City this is Clint
Pennock and median on Broadway of New
York and he's studying the ants in New
York and what he's found is that we
spill so much waste over into those
medians waste from our food that was
half of the carbon molecules and those
ants come from corn syrup and so this is
one kind of measure of how simple our
diets have become we eat so much corn
and corn syrup that it's actually making
the ants that live adjacent to us but
another way to think about this is to
look at in a sort of daily plate where
do our calories come from globally with
this plate shows is the proportion of
our plant-based calories that come from
different crops for people around the
world and what you'll see is that the
vast majority of our calories come from
rice wheat some source of sugar corn
soybeans and potatoes even though there
are thousands of other crop species we
could be rolling out this it turns out
is an incredibly recent phenomenon
historically people run the world eight
different things in different seasons
they different things as a function of
different cultures they different things
in different places and all that has
changed in our diets have been very very
homogenized and this in some ways
doesn't even show the full scope of the
problem because even within each one of
those kinds of crops often lead to
modernize the varieties that we consume
and so not only do we eat huge
quantities of corn but it's typically
one of two varieties of corn the huge
numbers of people depend on in the other
thing that's been homogenized is all of
those foods tend to come from very few
companies and so this figure shows the
proportion of seeds sold and owned by
different of the main seek main seed
supplier companies in the world and so
we have a situation where we eat very
few things very few varieties of those
things and they're supplied to us by
very few companies there are a whole
bunch of kinds of problems we can think
about with this situation is in terms of
health and well-being in terms of equity
but one of the biggest problems is that
by
doing this we put all our eggs into one
or very few baskets and this creates a
predictable scenario the predictable
scenario is that monoculture growing few
or one crop sets the stage for a cycle
of collapse and rescue where rescue
depends on one or another form of
biodiversity again and again this
narrative is what I'm going to come back
to in several stories today but we can
think about it first in the context of
bananas bananas are a totally ridiculous
fruit
Linnaeus Carl Linnaeus the father of
taxonomy thought it was probably bananas
and not apples that run the Garden of
Eden there is silly fruit there's you
know funny shaped they're yellow but we
didn't used to eat them we go back 150
years in North America we wouldn't be
having any bananas it would have been
sort of a novelty here and there but
then industrial banana producers figured
out that you could take one variety of
banana called the gross Michelle and you
could produce clones of it and that you
can plant that banana over huge
geographic areas areas that expanded to
be the size of entire countries and they
would all be exactly identical because
they were clones and so from an
industrial perspective this was perfect
every banana was just like every other
banana one banana was more similar to
the banana next to it than identical
twin humans are to each other and so you
could make lots of bananas you could put
them in a banana sized box you could
send them to people and you could
convince American kids that bananas were
good for them because these companies
also had the the influence of the US
government behind and so this were great
for the banana companies not so much for
lots of other people who are part of a
story and it became part of a sort of
Americana and so this is an
advertisement for bananas hand banana
rolls you know they're delicious they're
meaty they're nutritious they're not
really any of those things but we were
convinced that they were those things
but the problem with all of this are one
of the big problems is that this
simplification of Agriculture planting
one clone of banana
across the huge geographic area means
that if any one of those bananas a
single banana clone is infected by a
pathogen it can kill every single other
banana on that landscape and the banana
companies knew this from the very
beginning but everything was going so
well that who had time to invest in that
kind of scenario who had time to worry
about the problems when you could just
keep growing more bananas and so if
that's what they did
they grew these bananas at huge huge
scales and then predictably the Penta
pathogens showed up Panama disease
showed up and proceeded to wipe out
banana plantation after banana
plantation after banana plantation and
once it got in the soil you couldn't
even grow new bananas there we got new
bananas from somewhere else and so it
was a huge crazy problem and for a while
with 180 bananas were just done and then
the bananas and so it's what they done
was they planted a monoculture and
didn't plan ahead and that collapsed the
planet and monoculture and didn't plan
ahead and it collapsed this is a refrain
you'll hear again the rescue came from
the Cavendish banana and the Cavendish
was another variety of bananas somebody
else was growing elsewhere and it was
discovered it looked more or less like
the gross Michel banana so you could
convince Americans who weren't paying
that much attention to their food in the
first place this was the same thing it
tasted different but it'll look the same
and it would grow even when Panama
disease was present and so what did they
do well the one thing you would for sure
not want to do is plant this one clone
of banana again a huge spatial scale and
worry about the same kind of problem but
it's exactly what they did again and so
now the situation we face globally is
this one component banana is the vast
majority of what we bind the store and
this banana now faces the same kinds of
problems a new pathogen is emerged that
threatens the entirety of this clone of
banana and if it's trucked that banana
down it wouldn't ruin the banana
companies they would again look for a
new variety but it would destroy the
livelihoods of the people in countries
that depend on bananas this seems like a
it's a crazy story it's a story about
bananas that are growing clonally at the
scale of countries and yet it turns out
to be a very common kind of story in the
history of Agriculture and I would argue
it's going to be a more common story in
the future of Agriculture and so you can
you get this is so common that we could
talk about almost anyplace and so just
to pick a landscape I thought I would
talk about a landscape I know well this
is River Alta in the northern Bolivian
Amazon this is where I work there's a
graduate student you see me here with
much more hair although you can see it's
already starting to go right the future
is foretold
but in this forest that I worked I
looked at how long it took tropical
forests to recover when you cut them
down and when I paid a little bit of
attention to when I was a graduate
student but not enough was the reality
that this forest if you walk through it
it contains vestiges of a whole series
of kinds of agricultural collapse and so
what I'm holding in this picture those
are Brazil nut pods and those are there
because Native Americans used to create
conditions where Brazil nut trees would
be favored and so Brazil nut trees grew
up all across this region and so that's
why Brazil has largely come from this
region still today because of that
abandonment but the other reality is in
the same rage and you get abandoned
cacao trees in forest you get rubber
trees and forests that have been tapped
and you get cassava the faces all sorts
of challenges and so I'm going to pick
these stories from an individual
landscape out of the book to tell you a
little bit more about how these these
repeated episodes of simplification and
collapse look I'll start with cacao
because everybody likes cacao cacao its
chocolate this is a cacao pod this is
what this is what your chocolate comes
from historically cacao was dispersed by
megafauna so things like giant sloths
and gompa theer's would reach up grab
these big pods munch through them they
eat that that white stuff which is kind
of a sweet flesh and then they would
poop out the seeds and your cow fries
would grow in it and their weight but
then at some point Native Americans in
the Amazon figured out that you could
take that flesh and kids could eat it as
a tree or you could ferment it and make
it
your drink and so that was the story
from most of the industry to cow until
at some point somebody figures out that
there's an additional use which is that
you can take those seeds you can grind
them up and you can add things to them
and it makes it drink the kind of savory
hot cocoa which is what happens in
Central America cacao is not native to
Central America but it gets moved up to
the Central America very early and for
the Aztecs and the Mayans cacao becomes
a kind of currency you want lots of
cacao Montezuma famously drink huge
quantities of cacao every day and so is
a sacred drink of as an important trait
and it all depended on this weird tree
that used to be dispersed by the
megafauna then Europeans arrived and at
first Europeans don't pay any attention
to cacao Columbus and his third trip
encounters a poem to Maya and the boats
full of cacao seeds any Columbus notices
that when when one of the seeds drops
that the chantel my I pick it up with
the a Fitness that they might have if
they were picking up a stray eyeball now
it's a it's an awful commentary on the
time this one this knows what a stray
eyeball looks like but he doesn't
realize but he should take some of this
cacao home so he doesn't he leaves in
pee and so it takes a few more
expeditions and saw if anybody realizes
that oh this is something that should go
back to the Queen and eventually cacao
makes its way to Europe and when it
makes its way to Europe it becomes its
discover that you can use the different
parts of the cacao seed for different
things so you can make cacao nibs you
can make cocoa butter you can make cocoa
powder and all of those are used
industrially very early on pretty big
scale is a sort of a local market food
supply but as this happens suddenly
there's a huge demand and so we said
that suddenly there's a huge demand and
so many more cacao trees are needed but
the problem is if you're in the native
range of cacao or even in that the part
of Central America where it was more
heavily domesticated there are so many
pathogens of cacao the did you grow the
trees close together they get attacked
and so what people did was to move the
cacao up and over the Andes to where it
wasn't
and it could grow in sort of peaceful
harmony and huge densities and see you
Sokka confrontations like this and and a
few people got so rich off of this cacao
that like in the beaches Ecuador people
are actually sending their underpants to
France to be laundered and then they
were coming back and so they're still to
this day there's a small Eiffel Tower in
Ecuador that marks this incredible well
but predictably what happens is
eventually one of those pathogens from
the Amazon finds the trees because this
is what happens and destroys them all
and so again here they planted a
monoculture and didn't plan ahead and it
collapsed now cacao was never really
rescued in this part of Ecuador but it
was rescued in a way by geography by
moving cacao people were able to get it
away from the the pathogen that attacked
it in Ecuador also another pathogen
witch's broom and the place that cacao
is largely moved to was eastern Brazil
the place called bhaiya
now Bahia seems like maybe it's in the
same region as native cacao because
they're both in the same countries but
the truth is buddy is separated in the
native region of cacao the region where
witches root broom and the other
pathogens are common by grasslands and
so it was really kind of protected from
all of those pathogens much as if it
were on the other side of an ocean and
so as a result there was a huge boom in
cacao production in Brazil and by in
particular at Brazil would become the
number one producer of cacao in the
world 600 thousand hectares of
plantations just in this one region but
then what happens predictably the
pathogen finally makes its way to it by
yeah it done starts to spread it spread
some more it spread some more and this
entire regions cacao is wiped out as a
result Brazil goes from being a number
one producer of cacao to being a net
importer and Africa West Africa in
particular becomes the main producer of
cacao and so what's happened here
the monoculture and didn't plan ahead
and it collapsed but there was also
something else going on here the result
so a bad guy and early on in the story
people thought that maybe the bad guy
was somebody from West Africa somebody
who stood to benefit from destroying the
cacao by you until 2006 when this guy
came forward and said that he and his
friends had intentionally introduced the
pathogen of cacao from Rondonia in
Brazil right right across the border
from where I worked in Bolivia to buy
yet to take down the cacao barons so
that they could come into more political
and local power it looks as though at
least parts of this and maybe all of it
are a true story as a result most of the
cacao in the world now grows in West
Africa to a lesser extent tropical Asia
and to the rescue in this case was
geography but then there was something
else because in those regions cacao was
assailed by yet another pathogen a
pathogen that causes this full and shoot
virus I won't talk about it much today
the thing that keeps cacao from being
absolutely destroyed even before which
is grim arrives and most African at some
point it will is that the cacao is
actually defended by a kind of ant
called the Weaver and did you want to
know more about the story you can read
the book I don't have time to tell it
today but this is just another way in
which biodiversity helps to save us when
we put her eggs all in one basket take
another example rubber so if you go out
today and look at the tires of an
airplane those tires are almost a
hundred percent natural rubber if you
kick the side of your tire in your car
that sidewall is natural rubber if you
look at any big tractor tire those are
all natural rubber and that natural
rubber comes from rubber trees in the
Amazon those trees are tapped
traditionally by Citroen Garros ruff
rubber tree harvesters who would make
cuts into the tree and this is great art
by a rubber tree harvester and then the
rubber tree harvesters would go and
collect from tree to tree
early in the morning until late in the
day it was really terrible work and then
it would be shipped downstream and this
is yet another one of these stories
where the people who were selling the
rubber were making lots and lots of
money and the people who are running
these circuits through the Amazon we're
living hard often terrible lives many of
the people who work these rubber trees
died at the hands of the people who were
in charge of those rubber trees
meanwhile the Barons who were in charge
of making the money built beautiful
things like this Opera House of the
mouse and that was the beginning of the
story of rubber that it would only be
harvested from that region but then Kew
Gardens an idea and Kew Gardens decided
to contact this guy Henry Wickham Henry
Wickham was a funny guy he had the idea
you would go to the Amazon he'd make
great well he and his mom will does
scheme where he would shoot birds and he
would send the feathers of the bird
about the birds back to her in England
and she would put them in half and sell
the hats and they would be rich together
and live a long life mother and son but
it turned out he was terrible at
shooting birds and so this was not
working out and so to Gardens contacted
them my name is all either totally ruddy
dead to do something and they said what
we would like you to do is to get us
some rubber seed so that maybe we could
try to grow them somewhere else and so
we're not entirely dependent on the
rubber of the Amazon because all of that
rubber in the world was still coming
from those trees out in the wild then so
Wickham said yeah I'll try and
relatively quickly he was able to gather
seventy thousand seeds of rubber trees
of those seven thousand made it to
London of those twenty-eight hundred
percent to Asia perhaps a hundred
survived that trip and from those a
handful of seeds would then be good to
get a rubber Empire all of the rubber
and tropical Asia would come to descend
from that handful of seeds and arguably
just one or two runs of these seeds and
so it's a story at the beginning very
much like that story of bananas except
it's not as frivolous as bananas from a
consumer perspective right we lose
rubber with news cars when these planes
were in big trouble
well enter to the story Henry Ford Henry
Ford liked to be in control of thing is
very often that was people it was cars
it was machines but all of the things
that he built depended on rubber and
they depended on that rubber that was
now growing in tropical Asia because of
Wickham Henry Ford decided this was not
acceptable and so what he was going to
do was to go back to the Amazon and make
a huge plantation and when she grew
rubber trees and hide them to these
British tons of rubber and solved all
the world's problems and became a hero
but also connected his assembling line
directly to the forest what lots of
people knew at this time was that that
was very unlikely to work because in the
native region there's a thing called
leaf blight that attacks the rubber
train if you go rubber trees in in any
density of more than two or three it can
put them in a monoculture leaf blight
spreads tree to tree kills all the trees
lots of people have learned this the
hard way Henry Ford was different though
he would he would solve this problem and
so Henry Ford was given or bought and a
discount a huge hunk of land in Brazil
the size of the US state and that then
he said about clearing that land which
would he would modestly call Portlandia
and and planting rubber trees and so he
does this a huge huge scale huge expense
and he and he puts little towns up that
look to me like the towns of Michigan
and that other Orlan drug grow and
everything was going great and all the
people who might have told s'more but
probably didn't that this was going to
be a disaster had to bite their tongues
but the thing that nobody seemed to
remember was that in the other cases in
which people have planted lots of rubber
trees together the problems didn't start
until the rubber trees were tall enough
with their leaves touched and then the
leaf blight could go treat it free and
then the trees were toast
well for a while that didn't happen in
Portlandia the trees grew tall that or
even tapping rubber cord was a hero and
then it happened overnight the tree
started to get sick and the entire
plantation had to be
down and so nature won but it won
because he planted a monoculture it won
because he planted the monarch all
turned didn't plan ahead in the whole
thing collapsed but what's different
about this story is that it moves to
these stories after all this collapses
people at least get a new variety of
plant to try in this story and reports
that just give me some new land and so
we traded back or land eeeh he got a new
hunk of land in Brazil it was a little
bit different maybe he was gonna be
better this time he did exactly the same
thing he planted a monoculture again and
didn't plan ahead and it collapsed and
in this case there's no rescue there's
we not solved this story and so it's
true today that nearly all of the rubber
in the world is a monoculture of the
most susceptible variety all grown in
tropical asia and all it would take is
one spore of leaf blight to wipe it all
out within a couple of years and there's
not a solution if there is going to be a
solution it's almost certainly going to
come from the wild varieties of rubber
in the forests that might have
resistance to leaf blight that could be
bred in or introduced using new genetic
approaches but virtually no one's
working on this and so we just wait
until a disaster happens and hope the
trees are around another example cassava
I think most of us probably don't eat
that much cassava but globally cassava
manioc you go it's an incredibly
important sustenance crop upwards of
half a billion people depend on this
crop for survival it's 80% of the diet
in parts of the Congo Basin so hugely
important crop but it gets way less
attention because it's not a glamorous
crop and they're frozen the ground looks
kind of fine and yet very very important
well a mealy bug a thing that looks like
this animal turned up on cassava in the
Congo Basin and it started to cause
problems but because we hadn't prepared
we weren't prepared nobody knew where
what to look at nobody really knew who
to connect with it took three years but
when this was first found and when
anybody identified what it was 3 years
to put a name on this little thing which
would only do you become cassava mealy
bug for a little bit of a lack of
creativity and by then it had spread
across three or four countries and so it
started to look to those who were
involved in this story like famine and a
scale that people hadn't seen since the
Irish potato famine was about to stock
Africa and there weren't many solutions
because we didn't know we knew hardly
anything about this mealy bug and the
people dealing with it were too poor to
spray pesticides at the scale necessary
to control it in any way merely bugs
because that wax you see they're pretty
hard to control a class decides then
this guy Hans hare and a hippie from UC
Berkeley Swiss by but by birth but at
this point he was at Berkeley he decides
he's going to solve the problem and he's
going to solve the problem by going to
the native range of this mealy bug which
has been sort of just guessed that based
on the identification of what it might
be there it's a new species but it's
relatives are somewhere in the Americas
and Hans Aaron decides he's gonna he's
gonna walk from California through the
Americas looking for the cassava mealy
bug with the idea that it defines the
cassava mealy bug where it's native he
can find something that eats it grow
that up in huge abundance and release it
in Africa and kill the cassava mealy bug
and save cassava this need list is there
any seems like a long shot but he starts
walking and he finds absolutely nothing
he gets to Colombia he finds what he
thinks might be the cassava mealy bug it
turns out to be another mealy bug no
one's ever named before but now is
called herons mid-late lug in honor of
him but but really he's not finding what
he needs and so he starts talking to his
friend and he tells Tony baloney who you
see here Tony if you see a mealy bug on
cassava
make sure you collect it so we can
figure out you know anywhere you travel
is where this is native and maybe
collect what eats it well Tony had gone
to Paraguay to get a divorce with us why
and while he was there you know that's
not the most pleasant thing in the world
so he decided to do some collecting and
in Paraguay he finds this amusing music
but it's the same one quickly he looks
for things that are attacking the mealy
bug and long story foreshortened
he inherent by this wasp which lays its
eggs in the bodies of mealy bugs they
then release it at huge scales it
spreads across West Africa it controls
the mealy bug and it saves twenty
billion dollars agriculturally by most
estimates and the whole effort to
introduce this wasp cost about forty six
point nine million dollars and so this
is a case where the rescue was natural
history wasp a systematics the naming of
life a little madness that of herring
and a whole bunch of luck and so what
you see again and again here then is it
a pretty super predictable cycle again
and again monoculture puts us at risk
again and again what saves us is one or
another incarnation of biological
diversity our knowledge about the
logical diversity collections of
biological diversity and the passion and
madness of individual people it's I
think it's fair to say it's a very very
precarious situation on which all of
humanity depends and while we might move
that there's sort of some central agency
that controls all of this and has great
data I think in many ways we're really
in the dark ages and we can see this if
we compare what we know about the pests
and pathogens of our crops with for
example what we know about rare birds
this is kirtland's Warbler that you see
here on the Left kirtland's Warbler is a
rare bird of Michigan and we not only
know where this bird lives in Michigan
we know most of its individual nests at
the right you see a new pathogen that's
spreading of squash and cucumbers and
new england in the US and we have no
clue where it lives nor do we have any
clue where it comes from
it turns out as a general reality in
general scientists can tell you much
more about the rarest birds or even
frogs in the world then they can tell
you about the rare pathogens we passed
the threatened civilization via their
effects on crops just another measure of
this this these are the best data on the
distribution of birds globally and what
you see of these teeny tiny pixels teeny
tiny squares if you look carefully and
each one of those squares we know which
and how many bird species are present
but the redder it is the more species
are present this for context are the
this is the same data for human
pathogens and pests it's kind of a
surprise we don't know more about human
pathogens and pests we should but notice
the scale of the pixels is huge North
America
Brazil this is a special sort of
ignorance to give them what these
pathogens and pests can do our knowledge
about the distribution of crop pests and
pathogens it's so poor that we can't
even make them map and so what do we do
about this
the answer is knowledge but the answer
is also that we have to figure out how
to know enough about all the species
that attack our crops and know enough
about the species that can save us and
we have to have diversity in many
baskets all of this will require
different money more investment museums
research collections involvement of the
public and to consider this latter piece
let's turn now to sourdough bread I
promised we would give to sum it up I'll
say though as a loose - story that if
you want to learn more about the other
other ways in which individuals have
saved or failed to sale save our crops
those are in this book and so I'm an
armouring and you see at the bottom is
along with a small handful of people
responsible for saving the seeds the
eights of ancient seeds of Syria during
the war Nikolay Vavilov is responsible
for saving many of the seeds of the
world and that seed bank in the back is
responsible for guarding the single
biggest collection of seeds and yet
all these people have done these amazing
things we don't have collections of the
beneficial species of microbes that we
might want to have we don't have a
collection of things like wasps that
might help cities help save us from
mealybugs and so this is the story I
tell in the book but it's part of the
story the other part I can lead into is
sourdough
so sourdough as I mentioned is a kind of
bread that's made by leaving out some
sort of ingredients so that microbes
colonize those ingredients it's the most
ancient kind of bread it's the bread the
Egyptians would have made this is a
these are actually mummified breads from
Egypt and these were these were almost
certainly sourdough breads reliance on
natural microbes that compost them and
this story of sourdough bread is also a
story of humans because it's a kind of
bread that spread with us around the
world and each place we went we made the
sourdough slightly differently but the
microbes also evolved and they changed
as a function of world that we work and
so there was a moment in time where if
you went to all the places that people
had bread each bread would have had
different microbes but then like these
other monoculture stories the
monoculture returns in the 1900s people
figure out how to freeze dry yeast one
kind of yeast and sell it and so that
one kind of yeast comes to be the thing
we use to make bread in general so that
most bread now realizing on a mixture of
interesting microbes that add cool
flavor is the add cool aromas that
improve the nutrition of the bread but
instead requires the the domesticated
version of the yeast diversity we once
had a single variety of yeast the good
news though and I think very different
from some of the other crop stories is
that many people still have traditional
sourdoughs and so if you travel around
the world in different places you still
applying bakers at home with sourdough
starters that they've made themselves or
they've passed along generation to
generation
and so we started to think you know what
if you could travel the world buying all
of these different sourdough starters
and conserve them but also study which
of the microbes are best in which ones
we might need in the future when that
common yeast we used for everything
starts to fail or when we want different
flavors and so we started to think about
this more and really there's not
anything else like this there's a Museum
of sourdough barratto's in Belgium but
it includes a small number of starters
and we thought we could do it we thought
we could survey the sourdoughs of the
world and find and save them as useful
microbes and then in doing so we could
figure out what conditions paper the
most unusual microbes and maybe we could
even find heritage microbes in the verge
of extinction and the good news as we
thought about this was that we actually
run the largest group in the world for
engaging the public and scientific
discovery six faculty ten postdocs
hundreds of students and hundreds of
thousands of citizens we engage and so
we connected with all those people and
reached out and told people that we
wanted to see their sourdoughs to figure
out if they have unique microbes that we
should be conserving or they just
offered up new flavors and here you see
the beginning of this project this is
Liz Landis and Bennett walk and here
they are confronted with sourdough
samples that have been shipped to them
from around the world and quickly this
became clear that this was working these
are the sourdough samples we have so far
the dots show individual starters and
where they came from and so our next
step is to continue to work on these and
figure out what lives in them and our
next next step is to do the same for all
of the fermented foods of the world and
in doing this and looking at all the
starters the point is to know the good
species and the bad species and where
they are so that when we get in trouble
we're ready but we're also ready if we
just want to find a new taste or a roman
or some other way to enrich our daily
experience and it's working which is
super cool but the other reality that
was suggested to us when we started to
do
sourdough work was that this was really
just a beginning what if we can engage
the public not just in helping us to
document their sourdoughs
but also to help us to document where
mutualists of crops live the people
haven't been paying attention to where
pests and pathogens of the crops live
that nobody has seen yet and so we
started a series of projects to do just
that
this is margarita Lopez Uribe and she's
studies that a species of being a squash
bee that does nothing other than
pollinate squash flowers it's an amazing
cute little bee you see it here the bees
pollinate the flowers the male bees
they're kind of lazy when the females
are doing most in the pollinating the
male's kind of hang out in the flower
and then get drunk on the nectar they
just sort of wait there until the female
shows up another fly out and I made my
job but the females are these wasps
these bees are the best pollinators of
squash but we don't know where they live
until we started a project to get people
to take pictures of bees and other
insects visiting squash and other concur
bit flowers around the world anywhere in
the world and then we're working to use
with essentially facial recognition
software to identify which bees rent
which flowers and how these bees are
distributed
you're building on work that other
people have begun to do in which they've
documented the ability of facial
recognition software or software like it
to identify the pathogen to the crops
and so for example Marcel holiday we
read about in the book actually has been
able to show that he has an algorithm
that can correctly identify the
pathogens of a series of crops 99.5% of
the time and so imagine that we get
people to take hundreds of thousands of
pictures millions of pictures of insects
and pathogens and crops and start to use
that to document the diversity of what's
out there but also they start to
document the problems we're having and
so as another example or a Shapiro is
the world expert and concur bit well
what you see at the right here these
plants that have they've had kind of a
squash heart attack
their veins clogged with an or linea
pathogen their Linea pathogen is vector
by a beetle but we don't really know
where the beetle lives and we don't
really know where the pathogen lives and
so Laurie is working with people to get
pictures of squash from around the world
so we can know not just the pollinators
but in the plants themselves which
beetles are present and where do we see
this will so that we can anticipate it
before it ruins Halloween but also the
sustenance food of millions of people
and so here you see in high schoolers
helping with this project looking for
squash bees and looking for squash
beetles at a high school in Raleigh
North Carolina
another example Kaveri our Gupta is
working to try to figure out what the
pollinators of Chili Peppers are in
India chilies are not native to India
but we're embraced by the PI Indian
cooking culture and so become incredibly
diverse but part of that diversity is
due to the pollinators that are moving
pollen from one plant to another around
India we have no idea what those
pollinators are and so if they go
missing we wouldn't even know which
species to look for and and so camera is
now working to get thousands hundreds of
thousands maybe even more Indians to
take pictures of the insects pollinating
chiles and so we can imagine a vast
platform that connects us back to these
crops that connects us to sourdough that
connects us to all of these kinds of
observations somebody needs to make but
that a scientist we've not been able to
do but what can you do I think in part
there's there already movements at hand
that are making a big difference the New
Nordic food movement for example
emphasizes eating foods that are native
to their region
and granted not all of the things that
are grow in Denmark are my favorite and
and yet this sentiment of reconnecting
food what grows where people are is
hugely important in the u.s. the
farm-to-table movement echoes a similar
idea of connecting people to what will
grow in a region into the individual
farmers in their region and doing this
is really important for a variety of
reasons but one of them
is that it emphasizes diversity and food
it provides farmers a way to think about
other varieties that you as you begin to
appreciate different foods more might
want but the other message I want to
leave you with is that there's another
bigger possibility that by engaging
people around the world in helping us to
not only eat these foods and think about
what their local foods are but actually
to help us do science citizen science
that we can fill the framework for the
future that's very different a framework
in which the future of agriculture
depends a framework in which the future
of Agriculture builds and the work and
choices of scientists museums but also
you and so with that I'll close thank
you very much
thank you dr. Rob Dunn for that
informative presentation we will now
start the live Q&A portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the green Q&A button at the lower
left of the presentation window type
your question into the box that appears
on your screen and click on the send
button will answer as many of your
questions as we have time for let's get
started our first question is so what
can I do tomorrow is in as an individual
consumer do
that's a really good question I think
one thing you can do is you can engage
our sourdough project you can engage our
projects if you want to grow a small
garden you can plant squash you can
plant Chili Peppers and you can watch
them it's hugely helpful but but the
other thing you can do is to start to
pay attention to what you eat pay
attention to the flavors pay attention
the differences in variety you know that
I think we've become used to thinking
about you go to the store and it seems
like there are lots of kinds of things
but as you look in more detail it really
is we're seeing more and more creep in
but the average store is really full
mostly of boxes of corn that's ground up
and so but by shopping in that part of
the store that's still real life foods
you're shopping at your farmers market
and learning the different varieties and
favorite varieties you're not used to
it's actually a hugely helpful thing now
that's never going to be for everybody
right there's often a cost to choosing
new varieties and yet if even some
people choose those varieties and help
pay for them and give a market for them
it makes a huge difference in food
resilience if you think about the banana
example you know it didn't matter that
there were lots of Cavendish bananas to
save banana plantations when the grocery
Michelle disappeared it just had to be
somewhere and so if if some market is
favoring local varieties that might
someday save us it's really a big bear
and so that's one thing you know know
your farmers start to grow some food
even a teeny bit of food these are all
things the help I would say the other
thing is that you know every so often
there are opportunities to help support
research that doesn't seem very sexy and
the distribution of some plant pathogen
or you know to take the simple example
it would it would cost $150,000 we can
make a global database of where the
pathogens of pests of crops
lived that's not sexy it's almost boring
and and yet you know when you vote to
fund important basic work like that it
helps us all to take those next steps
thank you for that answer the next
question is can I send in my sourdough
starter to your project so yeah that's a
good question so what we initially asked
people to contribute sourdough starters
it was wildly more successful than we
thought and so we got a thousand samples
from around the world very quickly what
we're now doing is trying to figure out
how best to scale that up to be able to
stand below and identify that microbes
and in tens of thousands of starters and
so right now you can sign up to hear
about our results when they come out and
that opens in the future we find some
way to fund a sustainable model to
identify what's in when all those
starters around the world the other part
is that I would love to know what's in
different traditional yogurts and
cheeses and if you go culture to culture
there there are many different kinds of
fermented foods about which we know very
little and and for which it's entirely
possible that we're seeing extinction of
communities that exist nowhere else on
earth and so Rick right now the short
answer is sign up to here here more
results when they come out and will also
tell you if we find a way to take more
samples but also pay attention to your
fermented food and love your starter
the next question is do the microbes and
sourdough starters actually influence
the flavor
yeah that's a good question I think that
the industry is mostly assumed that the
flavor of bread is really determined by
the kind of flour you use or the other
things your add to the bread but a bunch
of recent experiments have made clear
that which microbes you have in the
starter make a huge difference for the
flavor of the bread from which vitamins
are in the bread for the even the kind
of gooeyness and the mouthfeel of the
bread they're really all determined by
what kinds of microbes we have and so
already we have a few microbes that
begin say ooh that one makes the bread
extra gooey or that one next extra sour
what we would like is to have a huge
panel of kinds of microbes that do all
sorts of things and so if somebody wants
to make a specific kind of bread you can
say oh that's the one that does that and
what's great is they most of the bread
you eat it's coming from very few kinds
of microbes and so you know imagine all
the flavors that you've never tried just
because we haven't we haven't found the
microbes to produce them yeah
okay we have time for one more question
if funding was a limitation what
research would you do
yeah so I think in light of the talk
today that I think we have a method for
starting to catalog save and understand
the the species living and fermented
foods around the world and so I think
that's something that needs to be done
and now is the time to do it because
cultural knowledge and heritage foods
are being lost really quickly and so
we've probably already seen the
extinction of a bunch of communities of
microbes unique to particular fruits
that nobody collected and so to really
travel the world and and find all of
these endangered can be food communities
and start to save them we have a giant
seed bank for our seeds we've got a new
bank that keeps our valuable microbes
and so that would be one you know I
could probably list about 50 things if
we kept going but that's it that seems
like a core one and it's a good one
because we know how to do it we just
haven't done it and it has to happen now
I would like to once again thank dr. Rob
Donnan Clara's presentation I would also
like to thank lab reads for making
today's educational lab test possible
before we go before we go I want to let
everyone know that today's webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing
through December 2017
you will receive an email from lab
letting you know when this webcast will
be available for replay
are you sure that announcement of their
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event that's all for now thank you
for joining us and we hope to see you
again soon goodbye